Armed guards and heightened security checks
didn't deter the thousands of people who travelled
to be here.
Many came to see a man who - despite having
left public office more than four months ago
- was still treated to a rock star's welcome.
In that time, Barack Obama's high regard for
the German Chancellor hasn't changed.
"First of all ‘Guten Tag’.
It's good to see all of you.
It's good to be back in Berlin.
I have to say first of all.
Not only do I love the city but one of my
favourite partners throughout my presidency
is sitting next to me today.
Chancellor Merkel has done outstandig work.
Not just here in Germany but around the world."
Small talk soon gives way to serious reflection.
Tight security wasn't the only shadow the
Manchester bombing cast over this gathering.
"The deterrence strategy that worked in the
Cold War had its dark side, but it prevented
numerous conflicts from escalating.
Not least because both sides were attached
to life itself.
That's not true of terrorist groups.
They're ready to sacrifice their own lives
to destroy those of others -- as we saw in Manchester."
Terrorism and war also preoccupied the people
invited to pose questions.
"Why did a Christian and Nobel Prize laureate,
repeatedly authorize drone attacks,
despite civilian casualties?"
Obama gave a frank response.
"In some cases - I know for a fact - that
actions that I took might have resultated
in civilian casualities.
Often times as a consequence of error."
Defending new restrictions on immigration,
Merkel said
Germany must resort to deportation when needed.
"That's a dilemma we have to bear.
We have to make the right choices about who
must go.
And on the question of fairness, I can only
say, we have to make those choices quickly."
Such words from the former President and the
most powerful woman in Europe
resonated with listeners.
“It's important to convey the sense that
politics doesn't just take place far away
from the public.
It's actually a dialogue between citizens
and in response to their concerns.”
“I thought it was good that he said war
should always be only the last resort, and
that each of us can do our bit to make the
world a better place."
And that indeed was the message here: that everyone
can be a part of hope and change.